there's the trapezium maybe yours looks
upside down maybe it's proportions are a
little bit different but that's
basically what you've got the thing
about it is those two parallel sides we
could say [ __ ] yeah excellent all right
so now you get to have a thing okay and
I'm going to give you one to two minutes
in your pair or if you're not behind you
to have a think about what do we do here
we played this game of trying to turn a
shape which was it from the into one
that was one that we could work its area
right so what are you gonna do I'll give
you a couple minutes to experiment get a
pencil out make sure you're doing this
part in pencil so that if you do
something you try something doesn't end
up being helpful you can rub it out and
try again
okay there's lots of different ways to
do it I know at least five let me assure
you once a day because of time what you
see how would you cut this up maybe you
actually want to cut up I have scissors
okay how would you divide this what
makes you a door what makes you take
away in order to make it into well one
of these something you know the area of
and had a calculator okay so just so we
clear
you've got your trapezium you want to
think of how to do something like what
we've done here maybe gonna add
something maybe you gonna cut something
off or rearrange it so you can work out
its area if you think you have man you
call me about that spoiler program okay
all right people are starting to look
I've seen about I've seen about ten
people who've given me much the same
eyes up it's not that bad but I wonder
as I rehearse it for you because what
everyone's giving me the same one if you
can work out what's on that so here's
the trapeze you know that most people
have drawn you might notice if you look
really can't believe it's easy bit
different to the one I've shown you I'll
show you why it's different in a second
here's what most people have done
they've said alright I'm going to put a
line down like that clever idea because
that's pretty much the same thing we did
with the parallelogram and then you say
what hey I've got one here that makes a
triangle over here I'll do another only
other side I'll do this okay so now I
have two triangles and here's where most
people would say all right now I have an
answer you take this part and what do
you think you would do it
at this stage very good so most people
are talking you know me here okay and
then hey presto you've got this show
you've got this new triangle over here
right and then what has been lost over
here gives you a rectangle so it's
pretty much this kind of proof very
clever idea I have one problem with it
then come back to my tree okay so I'm
gonna give this a go now might repeat is
not hugely different to this one okay
what is the difference how would you
articulate yeah once I decide the angle
yeah yeah okay so it's not it's not
symmetrical is it right now that's where
is yeah this is nice and imperfect okay
by the way this is called an isosceles
trapezium but this is not this is not
this side and this side they don't match
up and I can show you what's going to
happen all right let's do the same kind
of cut see you've got this guy over here
right and when I bring him over like
look this guy's sort of thin right so
when I put it over the other side is
gonna look something like this mmm I
think that's what you're going to get
roughly no I look at this side this side
versus this side that's about what you
got okay so this approach is nice it
gives you an answer provided your
trapezium is being friendly right but it
might not be so what else could we do
yeah why don't you took a serious take
it what you gonna do when do you have to
you guys can do kind of whatever you
like okay yeah yeah we use your own
let's take this idea of clearly you're
seeing we're gonna have to do some
rearrangement here right that's what
everyone's offices have in common okay
so now if you've drawn all over your
diagram like this okay would you draw a
new trapezium for me this time make sure
it's not your neat symmetrical one make
it kind of an unfriendly one because
we're gonna do a straight line to help
you and this is part of what you guys
struggle with I think right all you
didn't have things clearly labeled okay
so let's put some labels on this that
will help us you got two parallel sides
they don't know what they usually call
cuz they do actually usually have names
X&Y is one choice a and B is the arbiter
s I mean they just let us count doesn't
matter I'm gonna go with a and B for now
because x and y will come in tomorrow's
lesson so I'm gonna put this one I'm
gonna shade it in blue because I'm gonna
need it later I'll call that one hey so
I've got B down the bottom that kind of
makes sense a bigger base so here we go
okay so far so good
all right I want you to draw that
altitude you had before right so you're
like so far nothing much has changed I'm
going to draw it from this corner here
right all the way down now so far you
and I have done the same thing right but
now here's where it's gonna be a little
different okay I want you to measure
this life
I don't know how told it is on news it
depends I suppose maybe it's ten ten it
is eight ten years whatever now I want
you to have it so you're gonna draw a
line that's halfway up like so and it's
parallel to all of the other sites that
you've got this
so if this whole distance was 10
centimeters for instance you're gonna
have a five and five okay or if it was a
they'd have four and four so far so good
yep okay now because everyone's are all
different right like it might be four
and four five and five well mine looks
kind of like fifteen and fifteen okay I
want us all to talk about them in the
same way so whatever it is it's that
height and it's / - like this
hi / - lets see that yeah all right / -
they're both the same I've divided it in
half that's all I got
okay so here comes the magic now all
right
remember before how you did this you
said look this triangle and this
triangle they'll just nicely match right
but it was kind of a coincidence that
this side and this side were gonna fit
together okay
but have a look at mine right no matter
what kind of trapezium you've drawn I'm
still gonna get a match in take this
triangle up here right this little one
the smallest triangle in the whole bunch
and I want you to rotate it around this
point that I've got this point that I've
got here okay yes all right I'll come
over to in a minute
I'll draw it up so everyone else can see
what you should have right it's gonna
come around like this okay can you see
what it looks like
can you see how this one has come around
like that I've rotated 180 degrees okay
it's alright to pair I'm convinced if
you put yours down look at this same
thing but we're gonna do it with this
shape over here the one with the blue a
up the top okay I'm gonna do it much the
same way I'm gonna retain it around this
one okay it's gonna go around in the
opposite direction like Sun right now
where is it going to end up if you
rotate it around just like this triangle
it's gonna end up upside down okay all
right if I take this and I grab it all
the way around okay if I want you get is
this kind of shape
right now look carefully with me we
rotated it around have a look at this
blue line where should it end up where
is it now it's it's down here this is
where a is now okay so I'm gonna
highlight that with my colors that's why
they call it so there you go there's a
you know does that make sense okay so
what do I done taking these two pieces
rotated them around and now what I'm
left with
if I remove the pieces that have been
retained is what kind of shades that
that's a rectangle right now have a look
at its dimensions the area of a
rectangle right you've got sure I'm
right here right and it's H on to how
broad is it what's the breadth a plus
B's exactly right
so I'm gonna put those in brackets right
like so and there you go there's your
formula for at rafinha okay